Always.
Can't be cool.
Don't have it in me.
So, it's time for Drew's News.
Your daily basket of good news eggs.
Very fresh.
And with me at the desk is a good egg indeed.
It's Rossy Ross Matthews.
(audience applauds)
Hi everybody.
Is that some sort of yolk?
All right,
Well, first up, we've got some great
TV plans for you this weekend.
Tomorrow on HBO Max, you can watch
the 36th annual Rock And Roll
Hall Of Fame induction ceremony.
(audience applauds)
I have to tell you, this award show literally
had me so star struck.
It was unlike other award shows.
There's just something about it.
I can't wait to see it on HBO
because being there in person,
it was, it was really unique and different.
Who did you see there?
Who was there?
I saw Jay Z.
I hung out with him.
Yes, yes.
I saw my friend Pat Smear,
who I've known for almost 30 years.
He's the guitarist in the Foo Fighters.
They were inducted.
I saw H.E.R. walking by me, almost fell over.
Uh huh.
J-Lo!
There's always room for J-Lo, right?
I mean, literally, Carole King and Taylor Swift.
I never got a glimpse of them.
Like it was just too many people for one night.
Wow.
It was so special.
Epic performances.
And I was lucky enough to be there to honor
the introducing of my favorite band in the world,
that informed who I would become when I was a child.
The Go-Go's.
Wow, the Go-Go's
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
They changed my life, so I was so honored to do this.
Well, you didn't just do it.
It wasn't some sort of formal introduction.
You paid tribute to their debut album, Beauty and the Beat,
the first record you ever got as a kid, right?
Yeah, it changed my life forever,
because it was girls that were girls.
You know, a lot of what we tried to do
with Charlie's Angels was so informed
by the Go-Go's for me.
Really?
Which was when girls want to do what boys do,
you don't have to be and act like a man in order to do it.
Be a girl, but be capable.
Yes, Drew.
And I love, I love that when you introduced them,
you really went for it.
And actually we have a clip.
Oh really?
Yeah, take a look at this.
I always thought the Go-Go's was such
a perfect name For that band.
So full of kinetic energy,
it fits their music and their spirit and mine too,
and you know what?
You always have to just go for it.
(audience cheering)
Now my childhood fantasy is fulfilled,
but it isn't about me.
This is as true blue of a love letter
from their biggest fan,
from the first band I ever loved.
Here's a look at the Go-Go's.
Look at you Drew.
(audience applauding)
I feel like a non-musician inducting,
so, I also really, you know,
just wanted to honor the Go-Go's
as they deserve to be honored.
Well, from the Rock And Roll Hall Of Fame,
now we have a member of the Ross Matthews Hall Of Fame.
I'm talking about Betty White.
Aww, come on.
Oh, we love Betty!
The best of the best.
Who doesn't want to be Betty White?
If you don't like Betty White,
I don't like you, all right?
The comedy legend, she's got another
big birthday coming up.
On January 17th she's gonna turn 100 years old.
Wow.
What a life.
What a legend.
What a woman.
Holy cow.
I know, and still just better and better and better.
And to celebrate, CNN reports,
one company is offering to pay you
to watch Betty White's best work.
Anyone want that job?
Yes.
(audience applauds)
Choice Mutual Insurance is gonna pay
one lucky Betty White fan a thousand dollars
to watch 10 hours of her film and TV work.
And you can apply.
Yeah, you can apply on their site right now.
Send some love.
Betty, we love you.
I got to work with Betty White,
a bunch on The Tonight Show.
You remember I was on The Tonight Show
with Jay Leno back in the day and she would, right?
Oh yes we do Rossy, that's where we all met you,
and fell in love with you.
Isn't that crazy?
Well she would come on there,
and we'd do things and they'd be like,
okay Ross, you're gonna be in a sketch with Betty White.
I'd be like, are we sure this is a good idea?
Like me and a legend.
And what was she like?
She was like the nicest person, you know?
It was like, you felt like you were just
talking to like the sweet lady down the street,
except it was Betty White, you know?
And I'll never forget how kind she was.
Thank you for that fly on the wall experience Rossy.
You're welcome.
I, oh, that's exciting.
It was exciting, I know.
Well, I'm very passionate about this next story.
Netflix is moving on up to the big screen.
TimeOut reports that the streaming service
has purchased the Bay Theater in Pacific Palisades.
It's a legendary theater that closed over the pandemic,
but Netflix is opening it back up
to feature films in the Netflix library,
like their new Western, The Harder They Fall.
And Adam McKay's, Don't Look Up.
But what I want to know is, and this is important,
what are they going to charge for popcorn?
Oh, this is, this gets you going.
I just went to the movie theater
with my daughters and their two friends
'cause they were having a sleepover.
Okay, so it's four?
Four kids.
Four kids and you.
Two adults.
We bought stuff at the concession stand.
It was $170.
(Ross gasps)
And I sat there with my jaw on the floor
and I just thought, I feel very privileged
to have the means to say, I can afford this right now.
And I have every bone in my body saying
this is unacceptable.
But they charge that at the concession stands
because they have to pay their rent.
They're not doing it to us.
They're trying to stay open themselves.
And I understand that and I empathize.
I just want to find out a way that
we don't have to charge people
those kinds of prices to take
their families to the theater.
We got to make it affordable and
fill those theaters up again.
I'll be interested, because Netflix changed the world.
So maybe they can change the theater going experience too.
Of course they can.
Ted Sarandos, I love you by the way,
head of Netflix, old friend and a shout out to you.
Can't wait to see what you do with this new endeavor.
Well, before we go, we've got the perfect mini treat
that's just fun to eat.
It's time for food news.
(audience applauds)
Okay.
All right, in this world, you know,
there are two types of people, sorry,
two types of people.
There are pie people and cake people.
I am a pie person.
And if you are too, buckle up.
Because we're going to rock your little pie world.
Pop Sugar reports just in time for Thanksgiving,
you can now get the Dash mini pie maker.
It's only 15 bucks.
You can get this little pie press to make
delicious pies at home.
Look, we've got it right here.
Look, this is how it works.
See?
It's a little thing like this,
like almost like a waffle maker,
but for a pie.
Can I eat right out of it?
Yeah, you can eat right out of it.
Cause I just want to go right.
Drew won't even wait.
We have an apple pie here and a pumpkin pie.
Fifteen dollars!
I love this.
Thank you, Dash.
Get out of my car and into my dreams.